in the transcriptomics one course we
covered key concepts needed to
understand the analysis of gene
expression data we discussed how genes
are expressed in the cell and what
methods are available to detect and
quantify expression we also learned
about sequencing and how to analyze this
kind of data in this video we will
review what we learned in the
transcriptomics one course the central
dogma of molecular biology dictates the
flow of genetic information from DNA to
RNA and bend a protein in order to
create proteins from these genes RNA
copies are made in the nucleus and will
be subsequently transported into the
cytosol where proteins are built based
on their sequences in other words for
protein coding genes RNA is made from
DNA during a process called
transcription and protein is made from
RNA during translation there are
different methods available for
detecting and quantifying gene
expression reverse transcription PCR or
rt-pcr amplifies DNA based on 2 primer
sequences framing the section of
interest since PCR amplifies DNA and not
RNA RNA is first converted back to DNA
prior to amplification this is done via
a process called reverse transcription
in nature this process is carried out by
retroviruses in northern blotting an RNA
sample is digested into fragments that
are separated by size in a gel using
electrophoresis they are then
transferred to a membrane that can be
probed to test for the presence of a
hypothesized RNA transcript micro arrays
like northern blots a hybridization
based but in contrast to a northern blot
a microarray yields highly detailed
information about the individual genes
that have been transcribed these signals
are then detected quantified and used to
create a digital image of the array
finally the digital image is used to
identify the transcribed genes protein
coding genes in genomic DNA contain
large stretches of non-coding sequences
called introns that are spliced out of
the RNA transcript by an enzymatic
complex called the spliceosome before it
is passed to the ribosome for
translation
the parts of the gene that remain in the
mature processed mRNA transcript are
called exons these are the parts that
encode the amino acid sequences and will
be used in protein production
next-generation sequencing technology
allows for advanced studies of gene
expression because it captures a
snapshot of the whole transcriptome
rather than a predetermined subset of
genes which was previously possible with
rt-pcr and microarray technologies whole
transcriptome sequencing provides a
comprehensive view of the cellular
transcriptional profile at any given
biological moment and greatly enhances
the power of RNA discovery methods to
study this data we have to run
processing pipelines that turn raw reads
into structured data ready for analysis
NGS technology captures DNA sequences
and generates digital data using several
steps first RNA that was extracted from
cells is converted into cDNA that is
then sheared and placed into a flow cell
inside the flow cell cDNA fragments are
amplified using bridge PCR amplification
and the flow cell is then inserted into
the sequencer this machine uses image
analysis to capture each letter in the
flow cell fragments by analyzing visual
patterns and then converting them into a
sequence of letters typically NGS reads
are between 30 and 300 base pairs long
they consist of a series of letters T C
G MA recall that a typical RNA seek
pipeline includes three main steps
pre-processing mapping and
quantification pre-processing is needed
to clean up our data by removing the
adapters trimming some of the reads and
removing the PCR duplicates this is
important because PCR amplification is
not uniform across all reads then we
take the cleaned up read sequences to
map them onto a reference using a fast
state file for sequences of the genome
and GTF files for annotation based on
the quality of annotation we can use
various strategies for mapping once this
step is complete we have to quantify
expression levels and give each
expressed element a number this process
helps transform short raw reads that are
in the fast
you file into structured tables of gene
or isoform expression that can be
analyzed for expression patterns
pre-processing steps typically include
the PCR clean and traumatic options PCR
clean removes all duplicated reads from
raw sequencing data the presence of
duplicated reads from the polymerase
chain reaction amplification can distort
estimates of gene expression levels the
traumatic algorithm cleans technical
sequences from a database which stores
sequences known to be used as adapters
in NGS experiments from raw sequencing
data the input formats for the module
are fast queue and fast a raw sequencing
reads after cleaning PCR duplicates the
output is given in the same file format
as the input this new file contains
reads from unwanted information for the
next logical step cleaned up reads need
to be mapped or aligned to a reference
genome this can be done by aligning the
short reads to the full genome sequence
or to the transcriptome several methods
are available based on our objective we
can either map reads on the full genome
sequence and manually detect exons as
well as alternative splicing events by
finding exon junctions or we can use a
known set of transcripts from the
available GTF annotation file another
option is the Skip mapping altogether
and use a database of known transcripts
for alignment free quantification after
the pre-processing and mapping steps
expression values for genes and isoforms
are generated by a complex algorithm
that seeks to detect statistically
significant abundances of reads these
are quantified and displayed in an
expression table the Council of
expression can be an fpkm
or TPM after the table of expression is
prepared we can analyze the table to
study variability between samples or
perform biological interpretation of
specific genes or isoforms in this
course we saw how normalization of
exploratory analysis of multivariate
data called PCA are used to understand
differences between samples based on
gene expression data we also learn about
the online resource
that can be used to annotate a given set
of genes of interest David or the
database for annotation visualization an
integration discovery can help us link
found variation in expression with
function of genes or gene sets
transcriptomics one was a detailed
discussion of the role of transcription
and cell function methods of
quantification for mRNA an explanation
of next-generation sequencing and a
guide on how to analyze RNA seek data in
this course we also talked about RNA
seek bioinformatics pipelines which has
this general steps of pre-processing
mapping and quantification finally we
discussed the meaning of gene expression
for sample variability before tying
these two methods of biological
interpretation in our next course
transcriptomics 2 we will focus on
finding significant differences in gene
expression patterns we will start with
differential gene expression and
continue to look at typical challenges
that can be resolved using other
statistical methods we will look at
hypothesis testing p-values false
discovery rate and then use the D SEC 2
method to run a differential gene
expression analysis next we will explore
more complex variation by using factor
regression analysis as a result you will
learn how to detect obvious differences
between preset groups as well as expand
on that idea to more subtil differences
represented by factors that might
interact with each other